hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde ich habe mir einen Nintendo DS
bestellt mit
Gehirnjogging wie fit ist ihr Gehirn
dieses äh dr
kakashias irgendwie dieses Spiel auf
jeden Fall wo man so alles ankreuzt muss
man muss die Lösung machen und dann
zeigt an dieses Spiel was man für einen
IQ hat was das geistige Alter ist
du hast nicht mal Abitur Sandra und ich
werden gleich auf jeden Fall beide
verschiedene Challenges machen in diesem
Spiel drin ich habe es noch nicht wieder
geöffnet
sehr sehr provisorisch ihr kennt ja mein
Youtube Kanal meine Damen und guck mal
umdrehen die dreht sich jetzt zu mir die
darf nicht gucken Sebi Claudia Kati und
Jürgen ich habe das in irgend so einem
Store hier in Köln gekauft deswegen
keine Ahnung aber die jetzt sind hier
steht jetzt irgendwie dass ich Sebi
heißt aber wir sagen einfach ich bin
Luca wir machen einen Alltagstest im
alterstest wird ihr sogenanntes
geistiges Alter ermittelt dazu werden
drei zufällig gewählte Test verwendet
ihr geistiges Alter hängt vom Training
für ihre Stirnlappen ab
Sandra dreh dich jetzt um ich muss in
einer Reihenfolge diese Dinger verbinden
1 Wo B da unten ist
[Musik]
muss ich zu C ja
C3 was ist denn das für ein Scheiß hier
[Musik]
ich habe alles miteinander verbunden
Rekord Rekord Rekord
hat genau zweiter Test ich muss jetzt
angeblich das was links steht
Rechtschreibung wie viele gelbe Ziffern
zwei wie viele blaue Ziffern zwei wie
viele rote Ziffern
nein drei okay sehr gut wie viele rote
Ziffern zwei wie viele rote Ziffern eine
wie viele schwarze Ziffern 3 wie viele
rote Ziffern 5 wie viele gelbe Ziffern 2
wie viele rote Ziffern ich weiß nicht
warum ich dieses Video angucken nicht
ganz ehrlich hey ich weiß nicht ob es
gerade interessant ist das zu sehen
gelber eins zwei drei vier fünf sechs
sieben Alter krass wie viele fünf eins
zwei drei vier fünf sechs sieben acht
neun fünf haben wir hier die viele gelbe
Ziffern 4 Sandras Durchschnittsnote in
der Schule wie viele Anzahl rotierende
Ziffern 1 2 3 4 5 haben wir hier guck
mal alles richtig bisher wie viele gelbe
Sandra sei ruhig die sind hier im
Hintergrund irgendwelche Lieder blaue
Ziffern 3 7 8 haben wir acht wie viele
Nullen drei ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt
so lange geht bis jetzt irgendwie bis
ich nicht mehr kann oder bis ich einen
Fehler mache oder so Anzahl blinkende
Ziffern zwei drei haben wir davon auch
richtig wie viele schwarze eine wie
viele gelbe eins zwei drei vier fünf
sechs sieben haben wir unser Curry kocht
halt oben ne das auch noch mal so ein
Problem wie viele bewegliche 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 haben wir da
neun
neun zehn
sechs
was ein zwei drei vier fünf sechs sieben
acht neun zehn elf
hä
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 oder wie das ist ey das kann doch
nicht sein ist alles falsch Anzahl
bewegliche Ziffern also die sich bewegen
eine 2
das ist Scan 2,99 € will ich zurück
haben rechnen Sie das Ergebnis aus das
ist no joke dieser Modus den man glaube
ich kenne von Dr karwaschim also das ist
21 das ist 9 5 1 0 6 2 9 36 nein 36
junge 7 was ist das denn jetzt hier auf
dem Konzept raus zack 12 7 3 12 7 5 4
Junge sechs acht ey das wäre safe neuer
Rekord gewesen jetzt kriege ich auch
noch eine Zeitstrafe für diese 18
Sekunden hätte ich so gedacht ihr habt
gesehen dass es scam ihr geistiges Alter
41 Jahren das ist scam so jetzt kommt
natürlich der Profi das ist ja alles
mögliche sticken zu eng hier ne
Eins sehr gut
die ganze Zeit draufhalten
und neuer Rekord
[Musik]
ja das war menschlich gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend
wir werden
dann nein dort eure grünen matt Hexe
helmase
pink jung oben Blut 10 Kies Efeu März
Herz rundhalb grün grün und pink haben
wir schon mal dann haben wir die acht
und wir haben jung ich bin jung oben
oben ist der Stern eh voll hatten wir
damals vom Haus Welt ich bin rund
meine Nase sieht aus wie eine Hexennase
Hase ich hatte mein Hasen Gift ich habe
mir kein Wort gemerkt
[Musik]
ey das ist game
was für ja dicker
[Musik]
was für
Digger
nein das ist einfach nur reins das Game
Luca ich schwöre dir bei Gott ich haue
diesen DS gleich so was von in meine
Fresse
März wo siehst du denn
da du
[Musik]
du kleiner
ja
was war denn noch da
[Musik]
nein Luca das ist wirklich das ist das
ist scam das ist wirklich scam darf ich
mal
dein alterstest Gott ich habe bei mir
aber auch Fehler nicht angenommen hat
[Musik]
aber selber nicht du schreibst noch ein
Ding rein
mir fällt noch echt viel ein nee auch
okay
ein Wort schaffst du noch zwei Sekunden
ich wusste alle Begriffe irgendwie
[Musik]
das war Sandras letzter Test meine Damen
und Herren von daher klicken wir jetzt
auf Weiter und die geistige Seite
[Musik]
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann lasst
doch gerne einen Daumen hoch unter dem
Video hier da abonnieren mein Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke um weitere Videos
nicht zu verpassen ich bin jünger als du
ver